What led him to move to Colorado.
Oh,
he was losing his shit in San Francisco.
It was that night on the fucking motorcycle or I mean,
but how did he choose Colorado?
So this is a great story.
And like the early sixties,
Thompson had had a chance to drive,
um,
I don't know,
some sort of cargo.
I got friends car out to Colorado on his way to San Francisco in 1960 he ended
up doing a road trip up and down to San Francisco after he passed through
Colorado.
But he stopped in Colorado because,
um,
he had to drop off a friend's car and there was a woman there,
piggy Clifford who was a journalist and was his good friend at the,
um,
at the Aspen,
daily times.
And she was older.
She saw him like after driving 20 hours,
she's like,
Hey,
come in my house,
hang out.
And she lived right in Aspen and woody creek.
And so then in 1963 after sandy was pregnant,
Thompson came back from South America where he was a reporter and did a
wonderful job like reporting on how democracies were falling apart down there.
Him and sandy wanted to move west because the national observer was the
newspaper Thompson worked for.
They wanted to give Thompson,
I'm a position to be at Western reporter.
He was thinking of wanting to San Francisco,
but instead he chose to stop first where Peggy Clifford was stopped in Aspen and
Woody Creek.
And so he was living in an aspen and woody creek from August of 1963 to February
of 1963 and he was there.
This is where free kingdom begins.
He was there when John F.
Kennedy was assassinated,
and he's sitting in his living room.
It's,
you know,
10:00 AM 11:00 AM Pacific Time.
And he gets a knock on the door and it's this rancher named Wayne Vagner,
which is an old aspen family.
And the ranchers like the president's been shot.
Like,
what's more,
he's been murdered each debt and Thompson just like,
let's out a Saab.
And he begins to fucking swear.
And then he fucking calms down and he goes downtown,
um,
woody creek,
he goes to aspen and he just gets notes from people what their responses are.
And so when he then went to San Francisco to become the correspondent for,
um,
for,
for the magazine that he was working for,
he was having a tough time.
He was already wanting to flee because he got hell's angels.
He was able to stay in San Francisco longer,
right.
Report on them.
But by 1966,
67,
he was like,
this city is not a good place for me.
He has a great quote about like,
what would have happened if he stayed in San Francisco from 67 odd?
He's like,
no,
I would have burned up.
Like I would have been emulated right there.
And so when it was time to leave,
he thought again of,
um,
woody creek and of Aspen,
which was so different then than it is now.
And,
um,
that was the place that he decided to,
move and rent for a little while at first.
But then because of the success of Hell's angels,
he was able to buy Al Farm.
Um,
Aspen's very different.
But Woody Creek is not that much different.
Woody Creek is still pretty.
That's great.
But Solomon,
Woody Creek are great.
There's a great,
there's a place called the temporary.
They did an event with Juan Thompson and I like did a reading at it and like a
lot of Thompson's friends were there.
So I'm like,
I'm some fucking young.
I didn't know Thompson,
like I'm an interloper,
you know,
and like I'm out there.
And it was great to talk to everybody that knew him and to go through it.
And that's why I,
that's why this book almost killed me because I did a note for every sound,
smell,
our sight or comment.
Like if I wrote,
and at the moment Thompson felt,
what the fuck am I doing here?
I had the quote where he said,
I looked around then and I felt,
what the fuck am I doing here?
And I had that in the notes so people could see it.
And it was because I wanted those people that knew him well and respected him
and trusted him to not think that I was in any way trying anything,
but to make good art off of his life and who he was trying to respond to.
My fucking view of Trump right now and my love of his work in this moment.
Um,
why,
why do you say it almost killed you?
It's not possible to write a narrative and then also site every detail of a
narrative.
So each day I would spend nine hours researching and outlining with citations
ever.
I wanted to read it like a novel.
I want it to be like,
you know,
and at that moment I felt like I,
and I see the machine oil from the bay was coming off.
I wanted to read it vividly.
I knew that I had to support all of that.
And so I would spend eight or nine hours every day just on the pure,
um,
arrangement and research.
And then for the next six or seven hours or eight hours,
I would write the narrative and then I'd sleep for five or six hours.
You know and get up and I would do it again.
And I did this for four or five months,
you know,
after I was deeply into it.
And I don't think that's sustainable.
I think it's better in retrospect to go and report somewhere,
you know,
to like go and be at the middle of the Congress and take notes.
But to try to write something with the dramatize nature that I think Thompson
wrote well and having my protests on nothing like his,
I wanted my pros to sound nothing like the way he wrote,
but then to also have almost as many pages of notes showing my work,
you know,
like showing the math that went behind it.
So if I'm wrong,
I'm wrong,
but at least you can see it.
I think that was morally correct,
but I think that was too much effort when it comes to [inaudible] as you were
trying to do in a short period of time.
Did you have a crazy deadline or something?
Yes,
but I also,
I had a year and so on and I had a family and I had a,
a professor,
like I just,
I'd never,
when it came to writing,
had to do both those things,
which was to try to write it in a,
in a,
um,
novelistic way,
but then to also make sure that any question the reader would have,
but like,
why did you think that the dinner was at 5:00 PM?
You know,
or like,
you know,
why,
why did you think that the sun was coming up in this way at this moment to make
sure?
Because out of respect,
because with Thompson talked about was people are making money off.
I'm like,
Doonesbury yeah.
You know,
like that's what he talked about was people trying to make money off them.
And if I was gonna read this book,
it could have,
it couldn't be in that space.
Didn't he have a lawsuit against Gary Trudeau?
He thought about it,
I think.
I don't think he ever did it.
He talked about it publicly.
I think it was just,
well,
he became that guy.
Unfortunately.
That's what's really weird.
What happens slowly become a caricature of ourselves.
It's really scary.
Do you know,
um,
well,
it,
it's,
what's weird about it is that he kind of knew that it was happening.
Like there's that famous interview where he's talking to that British guy who
did a documentary about him practice with hunter maybe or no,
but yeah,
one of them,
but he's,
he's rolling a joint,
uh,
on the grass somewhere with that Las Vegas visor on,
and he's,
you know,
talking about how he's really become this caricature and it would be actually be
better if he wasn't alive anymore,
you know,
then it's breaking up with his wife during that.
It was really sad.
There's a scene in that where he hides where he's at like a parking lot.
He doesn't want people to see him and he's standing against the wall and people
are like,
come on,
we got to go.
He's like,
I just don't want anybody to see me right now.